do you want to drop an antique light
bulb like like a low value one and see
how they fare
this is a brand new smart bulb and this
is your standard everyday light socket
it hasn't changed much in over 140 years
you probably have a few of these light
sockets in your own home but think about
how much powering other devices has
changed in just the past 10 years we
went from classic wall chargers to usbs
and now usbcs but the light socket has
stayed the same we're going to explore
what makes this century old tech such a
great base for innovation today find out
why the edison screw socket is such a
lasting design and finally we'll test
out some of the latest innovations the
light bulb industry has to offer let's
get started
first things first we need to learn a
little bit of history about this edison
invention
and that's why i'm here at sterling
sound and vision in maryland to meet
chad shapiro he's been collecting
antique light bulbs for over 20 years
and happens to run a business selling
modern ones so tell me why the edison
socket specifically sort of remains the
same today well the edison socket as we
know it was developed about late 1881
and you can screw in a light bulb made
today into that socket other socket
designs were much more complicated to
insert or remove the light bulb the
edison socket was very simple to simply
just screw it in and anybody could do it
once edison was removed from the
electric lighting industry his company
was essentially transformed into general
electric general electric adopted the ac
system of distribution which would bring
electricity to many more than masses but
they maintain the edison design of the
light bulb we all know the gist of how
this combo works when you screw a light
bulb into its base an electrical current
passes through a wire filament inside
the bulb and the filament heats up so
much that it produces light edison's
socket delivers power so conveniently
that it's still in use in many homes and
lamps today it's even widely accepted
from country to country when wall plugs
aren't but the light bulbs themselves
those have gone high-tech that's mostly
because of something that you've
probably heard of light-emitting diodes
or leds basically they are tiny electric
nodes that glow using a lot less power
and instead of relying on filaments
which eventually burn out leds are
illuminated solely by the movement of
electrons they're about as energy
efficient as you can get in lighting at
least so far and they have a much longer
lifespan than incandescent bulbs the
reason they often look like this is
edison's light bulb shape is really
effective at sending light in all
directions that's what george yanni told
me he's the chief technology officer at
signifies phillips hue
leds are also the reason all these
dreamy color changing lights exist you
might have seen smart tvs like this one
with mood setting leds behind the panel
that match the image on the screen it
basically creates a more immersive
viewing experience however leds can take
on virtually any shape a lot of the
innovations go beyond just leds so i
brought a few products to kind of get
your thoughts on them i pick stuff
that's innovative and that screws into a
regular light socket so all right yeah i
think let's see this might be a good
place to start this shatterproof light
bulb
i have never seen anything like this
very interesting it's made out of
silicone it's led so it's energy
efficient this is definitely an
innovation so let's we would drop this
let's do it three
two
one drop
seems pretty shatterproof
uh i like it so we'll check out another
one uh so these are
germ fighting led
light bulbs well they are saying the
more that you put in your house the more
cleaning that gets done which makes it
yeah so maybe if i put four of them then
maybe i don't have to shower i don't
think so they made it pretty clear here
yeah they're claiming that this is
killing germs and bacteria and things
like that without using ultraviolet
because removing ultraviolet has helped
better light art museum objects so the
fact that they're doing this without uv
is actually pretty important in
maintaining
uh one of the benefits of led lighting
cool we're yeah i already feel cleaner
yeah i was gonna say we're cool yeah
same here so the last light source we're
looking at is samsung's freestyle
projector it's a new projector that will
include or the company will sell an
adapter imagine this is your kitchen
table right and this is your light
source this is your lamp this is your
ceiling light and it is projecting this
down on the table yeah what do you think
about it for a light bulb projector i
think it does better as a projector than
a light bulb i think this is a fun thing
i think of all the things we've looked
at though this is the least useful as an
actual light bulb here's the thing all
of these new lights should work in
edison's 100 year old socket and that's
really incredible i actually spoke to
all these companies to find out why
this old socket is still good enough
decades later and it basically boiled
down to three things it's cheap to
reproduce relatively universal and works
well enough to power a whole host of
light bulbs when you move into a new
place there is usually sockets in every
room george yani told me they can
leverage the infrastructure that's
already there so there's not a
fundamental reason to innovate on the
socket so that's why the socket's still
around but will it last forever we're
already seeing products that have a
dedicated light source built into a
recess fixture or a table amp etc you're
going to see more and more of that you
can already buy led lamps with built-in
led bulbs that you can't unscrew and
replace
there are also all these mood enhancing
lights like these from twinkly and these
from govi which can really enhance the
ambiance of your space and consumers
really like that stuff at least that's
what companies told me so don't be
surprised if you see more of that i
would expect though that the edison base
does still stick around for another 15
20 years personally i'm all for
companies trying to reinvent the light
bulb but if you go and reinvent the
socket good luck selling that